the City of Seattle has spent hundreds
of millions of dollars on the problem of
homeless
why hasn't it worked much of the focus
that we've had has been around this idea
of you know how do you end homelessness
you give everybody homes and while I
agree that that housing is certainly an
issue a lot of it has much more to do
with people having a place to stabilize
right it's not just about housing it's
about connecting people with with with
healthcare with with employment with job
opportunities with education and social
support and we look at the supply of
housing and build out more housing but
we're not really looking at how do we
increase the capacity of people to
afford housing although there are a
handful of safe parking lots in King
County the City of Seattle per se has
had difficulty in establishing a program
that works people who live out of their
vehicles then Park on the streets of the
city but because of parking rules they
have to constantly be moving from street
to street making it hard for them to
access basic services because there
isn't really a place for them in the
shelter systems there they're moving
into these vehicles long-term and living
there that way
like seven months but I've been homeless
for 20 years so it's been a long
struggle living from chance moving into
an RV and when I thought about moving
into an RV would be easier if I might
get more help and providers that will
help us get back on the right path but
they just made these more worse what is
driving homelessness nowadays yeah so a
lot of it what I've seen and
particularly with people living in
vehicles is that it's often it's it's
it's labor market shifts and so if
you're in between that low-income
forty-five thousand dollars that you
need to make maximum to get into
affordable housing and eighty thousand
that you actually need to live within
this community you're stuck go back to
the truck and eat your food this vehicle
is a way to that they can afford to
maintain a place within this community
to keep it there medical systems to keep
their kids going to schools to maintain
a connection with their VA whatever it
might be but okay